We're working our way through a series called Firm Foundation, What We Believe and Why It
Matters.
And this is going through our statement of faith as we're getting started as a church.
And each one of the doctrines that are covered in that statement of faith are really foundational
doctrines.
But the one we're looking at this morning is foundational to all the rest, and that
is the doctrine of Scripture.
Now on the back of your worship guide, it lets you know what we have written there in our
statement of faith.
It says, We believe that the canon of the Old and New Testaments is the authoritative
standard for the faith and practice of the church.
All Scripture is inspired by God.
It is useful for teaching, rebuking, correcting, and training in righteousness.
That statement keeps in mind the whole of Scripture and what it teaches, but it's
largely pulled from the book of 2 Timothy and chapter 3.
So that's what we're going to be looking at this morning, and Jennifer is going to come
and read that for us.
Thank you so much.
2 Timothy 3, 14 through 4 and 5.
But as for you, continue in what you have learned and have firmly believed, knowing
from whom you've learned it and how from childhood you have been acquainted with the
sacred writings which you were able to make you wise for salvation through faith in Christ
Jesus.
All Scripture is breathed out by God and profitable for teaching, for reproof, for correction,
and for training in righteousness.
That the man of God may be complete, equipped for every good work.
I charge you in the presence of God and of Christ Jesus who is to judge the living and
the dead and by his appearing and his kingdom.
Preach the word.
Be ready in season and out of season.
Reprove, rebuke, exhort with complete patience and teaching.
For the time is coming when people will not endure sound teaching, but having itching
ears they will accumulate for themselves teachers to suit their own passions and will turn away
from listening to the truth and wander off into myths.
But as for you, always be sober minded, enduring suffering, do the work of an evangelist,
fulfill your ministry.
This is the word of the Lord.
Well, let's pray once again as we come to God's word.
Lord your word is alive, it is powerful, it is sharper than any two-edged sword.
Lord, I pray that you would powerfully accomplish your work by your spirit through your word.
If we ask all this in Jesus' name.
Amen.
Well, like I'm sure many of you, I was at one of the local ball fields yesterday and we've
got kids involved in soccer and one of them, Levi, this is his first kind of official team
he's been part of and so it's been really good for him to kind of learn the fundamentals
of soccer and have some practice kind of getting to know how it all works and it's
been a great opportunity for training in all sorts of ways and he's grown in it,
he's improved and I'm sure he'll continue in that for years to come.
But the other night while I was at one of his practices, I was sitting there watching these
kids being trained in that and I overheard another kind of training or teaching happening
beside me.
There was a mother who had her little toddler on her knee and as her toddler was on her
knee she was singing a song to that toddler that I hadn't heard since I was probably
his age and that was the B-I-B-L-E.
I don't know if any of you grew up with that song, the B-I-B-L-E, yes that's the book
for me, I stand alone on the Word of God, the B-I-B-L-E and some of you, no you're
not going to shout Bible.
That's how it went.
I grew up with that one and in some ways it's a simple song, you know even bordering
on simplistic but it is pointing to a profound truth and that is that the word of God
is the strongest foundation that you can build your life upon.
And it's the strongest foundation we can be built upon together as the church and in
an ever-shifting world it's vital that we have a strong foundation and the Word
of God is that strong foundation.
It will remain sufficient for all time because it will last forever because it
is the Word of God.
And in 2 Timothy the Apostle Paul is writing a letter to a younger church leader
and he's telling them about the challenges that he's going to be facing.
So he talks about the challenge of hypocrisy.
You know people will appear pious but their lives will actually tell a different
story, they will be devoid of the power of God.
He talks about what you might call drifters who will go from trend to
trend and teacher to teacher just moving on to whatever it is you know they
want to hear.
And then you have the problem of what you might call haters.
You know those who will oppose the Word of God and the work of God actively
even sometimes the point of persecution.
But Paul tells Timothy that his life should be marked by something different.
When others are moving away because of hypocrisy or their own desires or opposition.
He says in verse 13 of chapter 3,
but as for you continue in what you have learned and have firmly believed
knowing from whom you learned it.
In 2 Timothy chapter 1 we see where he learned it.
He learned it from his mother and his grandmother Lois and Eunice.
So he's saying Timothy remember the truths that you heard when you were a
toddler on the knees of your mother and your grandmother.
Remember that truth that I then expounded upon further.
Remember the glorious things that you came to see.
Where did he see all these things?
Well verse 14 he says from childhood you have been acquainted with the sacred
writings or the holy scriptures.
So Timothy stick with the scriptures.
You know we're still living in the same time that Timothy was living in.
It's what the Bible calls the last days in between Jesus ascension and
his return.
We face the same challenges that Timothy was facing.
You know hypocrisy in the life of the church at large or people drifting away
or opposition in various forms.
We might wonder how can we endure when things get difficult
because it can be so easy to just go with the flow of whatever happens
to be happening in the culture all around us.
How can we endure?
It's the same way that Timothy will endure and continue.
We will endure when by the grace of God we continue to build our lives
on the word of God.
So whether you like Timothy had the privilege of growing up in a Christian
home where you were hearing the truths of God's word or you came to
faith later in life.
The same is true for all of us.
We must build our lives upon the scriptures.
And if we're going to build our lives upon the scriptures we need to
understand something about its nature and its purpose.
And then once we understand that we need to then respond to that
and avail ourselves to this wonderful gift we've been given in the scriptures.
So that's what we're going to look at.
We're going to look at the nature of scripture and the purpose of scripture
and hopefully with putting it into practice in view.
Alright so first of all the nature of scripture.
So what are we talking about when we talk about the Bible?
Well here it's called a couple of things.
It's called scripture or scriptures.
You know our Bible comes, the word Bible comes from a plural word
which means not just a book but a collection of books or a library.
So it's a collection of ancient documents.
In our text this morning they're referred to as the writings or the scriptures.
This includes the 39 books of the Old Testament.
And these 39 books were inherited by these early Christians.
These are the scriptures that Timothy had been taught from the time that he was a child.
And this is exactly what we have in the first part of our books
or our Bible, the Old Testament, these 39 books.
But then you also have the 27 books of the New Testament.
And these are still being written as the letter to Timothy is being written.
Alright so it's finished now but as Paul is writing this to Timothy
it's in the time when the New Testament is being written.
And what's fascinating is that these New Testament letters were being treated
with the same authority that the Old Testament scriptures were being treated.
Let me just give you a couple of examples of this.
One of them is in Paul's previous letter to Timothy, 1 Timothy chapter 5 and verse 18.
He's talking about something completely different
but he makes his case by quoting two scriptures.
One he calls them both scripture.
One was from the book of Deuteronomy.
But the second scripture that Paul quotes is from the Gospel of Luke.
You can go and read that in Luke chapter 10 and verse 7.
So he is treating both of them on equal footing, Old Testament
and these new letters as scripture.
Another one, 2 Peter chapter 3 and verse 16.
Peter is talking about the writings of Paul and he talks about how some of them
are difficult to understand.
I'm sure you've experienced that if you've read him before.
But what does he refer to Paul's writings as?
He refers to them as scripture.
So the apostle Peter referring to the writings of the apostle Paul as scripture.
We could look at other places.
So these 66 books combined together are the Bible
or what we refer to as sometimes as the canon of scripture.
We have that in the statement of faith.
The word canon just simply means rule or authority.
So it's a recognition of the authority of these books.
So these were not written many years later
or kind of chosen at random hundreds of years later.
When this canon of the Old Testament and New Testament was recognized,
they were being recognized for the authority that they already possessed.
They had already been disseminated in churches all across the ancient world
and they were already treating them as authoritative.
And when the canon of scripture was recognized,
they were recognized in the authority that was already there within all these books.
And you can read this in the early church fathers and the generations that followed as well.
So it's not just like a single piece of literature like say the Bavarghida or the Quran or something like that.
It's a collection of books.
It's fascinating when you look at just how this came about.
So these ancient documents were written over a period of 1,600 years.
They were written across three continents.
They're written in three different languages, Hebrew, Greek and Summon Aramaic as well.
Written by around 40 different authors from all different backgrounds.
You've got kings and fishermen and poets and prophets.
You've got this whole mix of all these different sorts of people and all these different places over this vast span of time.
Writing in all these different genres and yet all of them write in agreement with one another.
Although they are diverse in their writing, they are unified in their message.
Their message centers upon God's redemptive plan for the world.
When you look at how this came about, I mean it's nothing short of miraculous.
And the longer I read and study the Bible, the more this unity stands out as a testimony of its truthfulness.
I mean the whole of Scripture, no matter where you look, is hyperlinked and interwoven and interconnected in ways that are astounding.
And yet they are simple and coherent and easy enough for a child to understand.
But they're not merely significant. They are sacred.
So what are we talking about when we talk about Scriptures? We're talking about these writings.
We're also talking about it as being sacred.
So Paul writes this empathy here about verse 15, the sacred writings or the holy Scriptures.
So out of everything that has been written, these stand apart. They're holy.
They're set aside. Why is this? We can talk about, yes, their impact in the world, their provenness over time,
but their sacredness runs deeper than that. Their sacredness comes from their source.
So it's important that we see where these Scriptures came from.
We might say, well, we've already just heard where they came from.
They came from all these different places and people.
But what does it say in verse 16?
All Scripture is breathed out by God.
So while the Bible was penned by many human authors, it ultimately came from one divine author.
They were breathed out by God, given by inspiration of God.
Peter said it this way in 2 Peter chapter one in verse 21.
He said, men spoke from God as they were carried along by the Holy Spirit.
So like wind in the sails of a ship, they were being carried along by the Holy Spirit.
So yes, there were human authors involved with their personalities and ways of writing
in the context they were writing in, but they were being led by the Spirit of God
in all that they wrote.
So this isn't just true of Scripture in a general sense.
What does it say here? It doesn't say some Scripture or just Scripture.
It says all Scripture is given by inspiration of God.
So this is not just true of the parts we like or feel inclined to agree with.
It all comes from God. It all proceeds from the very mouth of God.
This is what Jesus said quoting Deuteronomy.
In Matthew chapter four and verse four,
Man shall not live by bread alone, but by every word that proceeds from the mouth of God.
That's another wonderful way of thinking about the inspiration of Scripture and what that means.
It proceeds from the mouth of God. He breathes it out.
Like I'm breathing out as I speak right now.
It says Scripture is coming from God's mouth.
So what are the implications of that if it's coming from the very mouth of God?
Well, the implication is that if it's coming from Him,
then the Scriptures will be consistent with the character of God.
They will be consistent with His nature.
So just let me give you three examples.
One is the fact that Scripture is trustworthy.
Like God is true and He cannot lie.
Therefore, everything that He says is true.
So since Scripture is given by inspiration,
that means it is inerrant in all that it teaches.
Right? So it's true. It's trustworthy.
Another thing, that means it's authoritative as well.
So God reigns supreme over everything.
Therefore, what God says is the ultimate authority.
So if we look at other Scriptures about Christ and how He is the head of the church,
well how does He govern His church?
He rules His church by the word.
So since all Scripture proceeds from the mouth of the sovereign God,
then it holds ultimate authority.
Everything we do comes under that rule.
Another thing, it is powerful.
So God is all powerful.
Therefore, His word is powerful.
Jeremiah says it this way in Jeremiah 23-29,
that God's word is like a fire,
like a hammer that breaks the rock into pieces.
So God speaks with power when He speaks.
For those of you who are parents,
you have a God-given authority in your home,
in the lives of your children.
But let me ask you a question.
When you speak or when you spoke to them when they were little,
did they always do exactly as you said?
The answer is no, no.
That's not the case with how Scripture describes the word of God.
So when you look at creation, what happens?
God speaks and He says,
let there be light, and then what happens?
And there was light.
So that's the level of authority here.
So God, when God speaks, God accomplishes things.
So it's not just what God is saying about something,
but what God is doing through His powerful word.
You can talk about God being the sustainer of creation,
as we did last week.
Hebrews 1-3, He upholds all things how?
By the word of His power.
His sovereignty.
How does He accomplish His sovereign purposes
throughout human history?
And in this moment,
well, Isaiah 55 verse 11,
God says,
my word that goes out of my mouth
shall not return to me empty or void.
But it shall accomplish the purpose to which I have sent it.
So God accomplishes His purposes by His word.
And that includes in our lives as well.
So God accomplishes His purposes by His spirit in our lives
when He opens our eyes to see the truth of His word.
So we might then ask,
well, okay, well, what is God accomplishing through His word?
And that leads us to that second point.
We've seen the nature of God's word.
It's sacred. It comes from Him.
What is the purpose?
Well, it says all Scripture, verse 16 again,
it reads out by God and profitable.
Now we'll get to what it says in a moment,
but just stop there when it says profitable
or it sometimes translated as useful.
In what sense is the Bible useful?
You know, I was having a chat with one of you recently
and you just moved into the area
and you, like me, had the Zillow app on your phone.
And you know, when you're looking for a house,
you've got one of these house hunting apps.
You're constantly looking at notifications.
Could you got to get in quick and see what's there?
But then part of the relief of finally getting a place is you then,
I remember the moment, I'm going to delete this app.
And it is gone.
So it was really useful and it served a purpose,
but that purpose was short lived.
And as soon as I was finished with it, it was gone.
Right? This is not the case with the Scriptures.
All right? The Scriptures aren't useful as long
as we are finding them useful or useful as they are kind of put into practice.
Although, you know, that comes into it.
We are called to put them into practice.
But here's what I'm saying. The usefulness of Scripture is intrinsic to Scripture itself.
Right? They are profitable.
They are useful because they come from God.
It's part of their very nature.
It's not so much like what use we think we can get out of them.
It's not what God intends to use them for when he brings about his good purposes in our lives and in the world.
All right? So what are they useful for?
Well, many things. We see that list there in verse 16
and other things in the kind of wider context and certainly even more when we look at the whole of Scripture.
But what we see here kind of really falls into three major categories.
And I want us to look at those together to see the purpose of Scripture.
So the purpose of Scripture is, I'll go ahead and give them to you,
Revelation, Salvation, Transformation.
Okay, first of all, Revelation.
God has given us His Word for Revelation to reveal something, to reveal what?
To make Himself known to us.
God has given us His Word that we might know Him.
So as we looked at Psalm 19 earlier, it's at the front of your bulletin.
It talks about, yes, God has made known by creation, but we're limited in creation as to the particulars of what we can know about God.
Who is this God? What is He like? What does He do?
God reveals all of this through His written Word.
He tells us who He is.
He doesn't leave us to our own devices to try to figure Him out.
He graciously made Himself known in a way that we can understand, namely through words in a book.
So while the Bible is written for us, it is, here's an implication of this, it is not ultimately written about us.
It is about God.
We've got this narcissistic tendency to sort of flip this around and make the Bible about us.
What does this say to me?
We need to look for ourselves in there.
But the revelation of God in Scripture centers on the ultimate revelation of Himself, which is in the person of His Son, Jesus Christ.
So this is what we see in verse 15, for example.
It says, from childhood you have been acquainted with the sacred writings which are able to make you wise for salvation through faith in Christ Jesus.
So the Scriptures reveal Christ to us, and Christ reveals God.
So it's through God's written Word that we see the Word made flesh, which is Jesus.
When we fail to grasp this that Jesus is at the center of what God's Word teaches.
We end up misusing the Bible and turning it into a collection of stories that are just mere examples to us.
Or a book of instructions, which we have moral lessons to draw from.
Now Scripture certainly has rules, moral lessons and examples to follow it and all of that, sure.
But all of that is stemming from what it's telling us about who God is and what He has done for us in Christ.
Scripture shows us who He is, what He has done, and the life that we're called to live which is lived out of our union with Him.
So we see who Jesus is, and that is what changes us, enables us to live the lives that we were made for.
One of my favorite accounts in Scripture is in Luke 24.
Jesus is, he's died and he's risen again, and he appears to two disciples on the road to Emmaus.
And as he's going down the road to Emmaus, you think, well what are the sorts of things that Jesus would discuss with his disciples after he's risen again from the dead?
Like if the risen Christ met with us this morning, we might think, well if Jesus met with us in person,
like would we even need the Bible anymore because hey we have the Word Himself with us.
So it's amazing what Jesus does. When he meets with these disciples, they are with the risen Christ Himself,
and he says, here I want to show you something, in the Scriptures.
So we're told that Jesus takes them into the Scriptures, and in the Scriptures he shows them all the things concerning himself.
So in what Jesus says to these disciples, you have a couple of things going on.
You see what he says, like Scripture is all about him, it's revealing him.
But it also elevates the importance of Scripture where you might think, well, oh no, it's just about experiencing a vague sense of who Jesus is.
But if we were to meet with Jesus, he would say, look at what I've revealed to you about myself in my Word.
Right, so Jesus shows us what it means to value his Word and to know him through it by his Spirit.
Okay, so it's about revelation, this is who God is.
But it's also about salvation.
We're told that these sacred writings are able to make you wise for salvation through faith in this Christ Jesus.
So the Bible not only tells us about who God is, but what he has done to save us.
Only a few days ago I went to a mechanic to get a couple of tires changed on my car, and you know what?
I don't know a thing about cars, and I think that was obvious when I walked in the door and started talking with them.
And so they went and this chain placed that shall not be named.
And they changed the tires, and I heard them call my name, so I came around the corner and they said, I'm sorry, we've got bad news.
And then they started to explain the bad news of all the different things that needed to be changed.
They're talking about wheel hubs and rotors and brakes and all the rest.
And I said, well how much is that going to cost?
And they said, well that'll be $2,400. Will you be paying on the same card?
And I said, hang on, hang on, just a second.
And so I said, well like how bad is it?
And they were saying, well it is absolutely urgent.
And some of it is even, it runs the risk of it causing a catastrophic accident.
I think it was the language that they used.
Like if you're going to drive off this lot, you're taking your life into your hands and the lives of all those you're driving around.
So really sorry for putting all of you at risk.
But I took the decision to, I said well I'm going to go for a second opinion.
And before then, sorry, they then gave me a spiel about how I should take out a credit card with them.
And I started thinking, was that what all of this was about?
Commission and all.
So I took the car to another mechanic, he's an old family friend.
And he looked the car over through and through.
And then there's another guy there, he looked the car over through and through.
And they came to me and you know what they said?
They said there is absolutely nothing wrong with it at all.
They said, what they said to you, they said I wish we could take the same mechanic and say, can you show us what the problem is?
Can you prove to us that's a problem?
And so I was helpless.
I didn't know how to accurately diagnose my problem or what the appropriate solution should be.
So I'm glad that I went to somebody who could actually show me what that was and save me $2,400.
Now if that's the case with, say our vehicles or our money, you know, we want somebody to accurately diagnose that we might have an accurate solution.
Like how much more should that be with our own ourselves?
You know, our eternal selves, our souls.
You know, if we are honest, we know that something is broken inside of us and it needs to be fixed.
And it's hard to find a reliable guide who will tell you what the problem is and what the solution is.
You know, some people will tell you, you know, there isn't a problem.
You are absolutely fine just as you are. You are enough.
I'm sure you'll see a commercial on TV that will tell you just that before the day is over.
And somebody else will say, no, you're broken. You've got a problem.
And here is the solution.
They'll tell you all the things that you need to do to fix yourself or to buy or whatever it is.
So who can we trust?
That's the wonderful thing about the Word of God is that in the Word of God it shows us the way of salvation.
It, with pinpoint accuracy, describes the human condition and the problem of it, but also the solution to it.
So what is the problem?
Well, we'll look at it in more depth in a couple of weeks, but sin is the problem.
Scripture tells us about how sin came into the world and it describes all the corruption that came into the world as a result.
That this sin has affected us all to the point that we are all dead spiritually, completely cut off from the source of life, separated from God.
That's our problem.
So what's the solution?
Well, salvation.
In the Old Testament, we see all these promises that God made of how He was going to send a Savior.
We see all these pictures in the Old Testament Scriptures as well that point forward to the arrival of that coming Savior.
So we see those promises made and in the New Testament we see these promises kept and fulfilled.
That Christ who was promised came and He lived a perfect life that we failed to live.
And He died the death that we deserved to die.
And He rose again that we might have life in Him and be brought back into a right relationship with God.
Shorthand is to say He came to be the Savior of the world.
So salvation, the salvation of Scriptures isn't about what we do to bring ourselves to God.
It's not like a rulebook that says, well, you keep this, you keep this, and keep this, and maybe God will accept you.
No, Scriptures is God showing us what He has done to bring us to Himself, to make us new.
So how can we know that we've experienced the salvation that we've been brought to God?
Well, verse 15 tells us, He came to save us through faith in Christ Jesus.
You don't put your trust in yourself.
And what you can do, you put your trust in Jesus and in Him alone because of what He has done for you.
You know that God who kept His Word in sending Jesus will also keep His Word that He saves everyone who puts their faith in this Jesus.
All right, so it shows us revelation of God, salvation, how God brings us to Himself.
But Scripture is also there for the purpose of, lastly, transformation.
All right, so it's not just about learning some facts.
It's not just about helping us to feel a bit better.
It's about truly transforming our lives.
So they're profitable for, let's just look at what it says in verse 16, for teaching.
So we're given things to learn, so we definitely need to read these words and to think them through and to hear them taught.
But it isn't just about information.
Once again, it's about transformation.
So we learn these that we might truly know God and truly know what it means to live a life pleasing to Him.
They're also for the purpose of reproof and correction.
So Scriptures don't just comfort us.
They also convict us about the things that are wrong.
So yes, they positively show us the way that we should go, but they also negatively warn us about the ways we shouldn't go.
If you're walking down a trail that's got a cliff edge beside it, like, sure, you want a sign that tells you, like, this is the trail.
But it's also helpful to have a sign that says there's a cliff here.
Like we need the warnings as well as the positive encouragement as well.
We need both.
But also Scripture is there for training in righteousness.
You know, when we think about little ones being trained in soccer or whatever sport it is, like, yeah, they need to be trained for sure.
And they need to put it into practice.
But you don't just take one of these little kids and like stick them in the World Cup and like, off you go.
Hope it goes well.
As cute as that would be to see that happen.
We know that it's going to, it's going to take time, their development.
It's going to take years as they continue in this practice, whatever it is.
Same can be true with a musical instrument of whatever it is you're being trained in.
The same is true with training in righteousness.
When you put your faith in Christ, when you're saved, you are changed instantaneously.
You were given a new life right then, but it takes a lifetime for that to come through as God continually transcends.
He continually transforms us into the image of His Son.
So yeah, the Bible doesn't tell us everything that we can, you know, that is out there to be known about, say, science or mathematics.
Or you might open it thinking like, what job am I supposed to accept?
Is it this one or is it this one?
And we find a verse, you know, it's not there for that.
It's a faithful and sufficient guide though to help us to navigate all of life, whatever we're facing.
We might know what it is to please God in every area of life and depend on Him in all that we do.
So Paul tells Timothy here that God has provided everything that He needs, not only to have new life in Jesus, but also to mature as a Christian.
So he tells Timothy that the Scriptures are verse 17, there that the man of God may be complete, equipped for every good work.
So when you go a bit further down in verse 3 of chapter 4, Scripture is referred to as sound teaching.
You know, if you're going to live a healthy life, you need to eat healthy food.
Like you can't just survive on junk food alone.
Like as hard as it is to eat healthy, like we need that in order to live a healthy life.
Well, why am I saying that? The word sound there means healthy, right? Sound teaching.
Alright, so if we're going to live the life that we have been saved for, created for, it will involve in taking the right things.
It will involve receiving healthy teaching that we might grow in the health that God has designed us for.
And if we're going to grow as a healthy church, it will only happen as we receive the truth of the Word of God.
So this is why Paul charges Timothy, 2 Timothy chapter 4 and verse 2, preach the Word to Timothy.
Preach the Word because it's in the Word of God that he guides his people and provides them with the nourishment that they need,
that they might grow in the likeness of Jesus.
So if we're going to grow into being a healthy church, then the Word of God must be central in all that we do.
It must shape every aspect of our lives together. So weekend and week out, we are going to return again and again to this book,
asking God to speak to us and to accomplish his purpose in our lives through it, by his spirit and in Jesus.
You know, if we're going to be healthy people individually too, spiritually healthy.
If we're going to truly know Christ and grow in him, we must continually come to God's Word ourselves as well.
So let me just ask as we close, just basic questions. One is, are you hungry for God's Word?
You know, we can kind of gorge ourselves on so many other things that were quick to run to that.
God has provided us the nourishment that we need for life in his Word. So are we hungry for that?
Are we listening to God's Word? Are we eager to read it and to hear what it is saying?
Not as a check the box exercise, but because we want to know God and to know more of him and to walk with him,
to know his presence in our lives.
And then the last question is, are we sharing that Word with others?
I'm encouraged here. You know, Paul's got this charge to Timothy, preach the Word.
And like as someone who preaches the Word, I take that admonition for myself.
Like, you don't need to hear my ideas about things or whatever.
You don't need to hear my like, you know, 10 tips for whatever on a Sunday.
We all need the Word of God. So we're called to preach the Word of God.
But where did Timothy, who's being charged to preach the Word of God,
where was that Word first proclaimed to him? Remember where we started?
On the knees of a mother, of a grandmother.
That's how the Word of God is going out powerfully through Timothy.
It's because he had a mother and a grandmother who took that charge seriously as well.
So the Lord can use all of us to speak his Word into the lives of other people,
into one another's lives, in the lives of the children that God has entrusted to us.
May the Lord use us to accomplish his purposes in the world
through proclaiming his Word. Let's pray, shall we?
Lord, how we thank you for the Bible.
Lord, thank you so much for not leaving us in this world
to kind of try to find our way ourselves, or because we could not do it.
Lord, thank you for speaking to us.
And Lord, we thank you especially for how you have made yourself known to us
by your Word in the person of your Son, Jesus Christ.
And so Lord, I pray that you would show us more and more of him as we come to your Word.
Lord, I pray that we would open up our Bibles, that we would read it,
that we would be eager to listen to it, to hear it proclaimed.
Because we want to know you.
And Lord, I pray that you would help us by your Spirit to know more of Jesus,
that we might be transformed into his likeness.
Lord, as we come to your Word, I pray that we would not be hearers only,
but that you would make us doers of your Word, and even proclaimers of it.
If we ask all this in Jesus' name, amen.